One day you look in the mirror and
something feels different. Not just the
gray hairs or the wrinkles. It's that
nagging thought in the back of your
mind. Am I getting old? You think back
to your last doctor's visit. The lab
results weren't great. Blood sugar keeps
creeping up. Cholesterol is getting
worse. And the doctor said, "It's not
that bad. It happens to most people your
age. We don't need to put you on any
medication yet. But that phrase stuck
with you. Most people your age. What age
is that? When the aches start showing
up, when fatigue lingers, when the brain
fog sets in. It's not that it's
terrible, just not like it used to be.
Maybe it's time to start changing some
things while there is still time. Hello,
health champions. Today we're going to
talk about the top 10 foods to eat after
you've reached the age of 50. Most
people as they grow up feel pretty much
invincible and then up to age 30 it's
pretty much a free ride. But after 50
things really change. It's sort of like
this. If we think about your vitality
and we plot that as 100%
and we plot your age here and we got 10
20 30 40 50 then as you develop as you
are in your youth and in your teens your
body develops without you having to do
anything. So at about age 25 you reach
your peak and then it's pretty much
plateaus for a few years but after the
age of 30 it starts going back down
again so that at age 50 you are on the
way down so to speak and this is where
you start noticing some of the earliest
signs of aging. And our goal is not to
try to never age because we don't know
how to do that yet. But what we do know
is if we make some lifestyle changes, if
we do the right things from an early
age, now we can get this peak a little
bit higher and then we can start going
down. We can degenerate much much slower
so that the time where you start having
symptoms is much much later in life. But
after age 50, some things change that
you may not even notice. Most people are
going to start losing muscle mass unless
they're very physically active. You're
going to start losing collagen and
elastin, and these are the components of
bone and cartilage and skin. And when
you start losing those, now you become
stiffer. And also what happens that
people didn't necessarily think about
before is you become more insulin
resistant. So, even if you haven't
started gaining weight or become
diabetic, for most people, they're
heading in that direction, even if they
haven't really changed much of what they
eat. They could eat certain things when
they were 30, but it doesn't mean that
you can necessarily eat those things
anymore. And for most people, you're
also starting to get more oxidative
stress and inflammation that shows up in
the form of a lowgrade chronic
inflammation that starts driving
degenerative disease and premature
aging. So when we talk about the best
foods, it needs to be foods that support
all these factors and can start building
your body and reversing or slowing that
degeneration. And food number one is
salmon and or sardines. And it could
also be some other fatty fish. But do
your research and make sure that it is
high in the essential fatty acids, the
omega-3s, EPA, and DHA, because fatty
fish is the richest natural source of
these things. And there's many benefits
to this, especially as you age. It has
the ability to reduce or normalize your
inflammatory response. It supports brain
and artery health. Uh part of that is
because it reduces inflammation. Part of
it is that most of your brain is
actually built out of DHA. And DHA is
directly linked to the rate of brain
shrinkage. Meaning if you have high
levels of DHA as opposed to not enough,
then your brain is going to shrink and
degenerate less. And also having enough
DHA has been shown to improve memory and
reduce the neurological decline compared
to people who have less of this DHA. But
the scary thing is because most people
don't eat fish and because we eat a lot
of processed foods, most people are
deficient in these omega-3s.
And fish or fish oil therefore is not
really optional. If you don't eat fish,
if you don't eat fatty fish, probably
three times a week or more, then you
really need to be taking a fish oil
supplement. Food number two is avocados,
and they are very rich in potassium and
monounsaturated fatty acids, which helps
the heart because it helps improve
vascular elasticity. So, if the blood
vessels are elastic, then it's easier
for the heart. it doesn't have to work
as hard to pump the blood through the
blood vessels and that makes it also
easier to maintain normal blood
pressure. Avocados are also very high in
fiber and very low in net carbs. And
this is a very important factor for
insulin resistance as you become less
carbohydrate tolerant. And it helps you
stabilize insulin with less influence
responses and it helps maintain your
blood glucose. It also helps with the
absorption of vitamin A, D, E, and K.
all the fat soluble vitamins as well as
the carotenoids like beta carotene which
is previtamin A that your body can
convert into vitamin A. Number three is
cruciferous vegetables and these are
things like broccoli, Brussels sprouts,
kale, cauliflower, cabbage and arugula.
And there are many more than this. So if
you want to go do a search to get more
variety in then that'd be a great idea.
They help enhance liver detox. So they
have they contain compounds that enhance
the liver's ability to assist the the
liver in doing its detox. And one of the
things the liver does in that regard is
to improve estrogen metabolism. So all
hormones like estrogen and testosterone
and all the other hormones, they have a
certain half-life. They are only
supposed to be active for so long and
then the liver breaks them down. That is
how we can balance out hormones. And if
we have enough of these compounds that
are contained in cruciferous vegetables,
now the liver can do that better and in
that becomes very important during
menopause for women and for prostate
health for men. They also contain very
high levels of antioxidants that help
the body control inflammation and
oxidative stress. Food number four is
pastured eggs. Not pasteurized eggs, but
pastured meaning the hens that lay them
are living their life on pastures.
And if they do that, then they contain
high levels of choline, lutein, and
zeazanthin,
which are very important for memory and
nerve signaling and also for eye health
to protect your vision as you age. And
they also support the production of
acetal choline, which is a
neurotransmitter
that is super important for learning and
memory. And they're also very rich in
DHA. Not as abundant as the fish we
talked about first, but it is an
important they have enough that it's an
important source of DHA for the brain.
And also very important for the brain as
you age is cholesterol. If you have very
low levels of cholesterol, that
dramatically increases your risk of
dementia. And these pastured eggs also
contain the fat soluble vitamins A, D,
E, and K. But it is important that we
eat the whole egg, not just the egg
white. And it is important that we get a
good quality egg. And why is that?
Because most of the nutrients that we
talked about, they are in the yolk. And
if we want to utilize the protein to
build body building blocks to build
tissue, then we need the combination of
protein of amino acids from the yolk and
the white combined. That is the only way
that we can utilize a significant amount
of those amino acids. And if we compare
the really good quality eggs, the
pastured eggs where the hens walk
outside and they get sunshine and fresh
air and they get some exercise and they
eat some bugs and some worms and some
grass and some seeds. That's a very
healthy hen as opposed to the kayo
chicken, the concentrated animal feeding
operation where the hens are treated
atrociously. They never see daylight.
They're just fed hormones and whatever
it takes to make them grow fast. They're
miserable. Then if we compare the
nutrients that shows up in the eggs as
well. So these essential fats that we
talked about, the EPA and the DHA, you
get two to three times more in the
pastured eggs. Vitamin D, you get three
to six times more in the pastured eggs.
Vitamin E you get twice as much beta
carotene that we can turn into vitamin A
have seven times as much and this is
what gives the egg yolk their color. So
some manufacturers in the kayo
operations or in the the less natural,
the less caring operations, they might
feed the hens some beta carotene to try
to make the yolks look healthier. And
you probably get better looking yolk and
you get some more beta carotene, but
it's a trick. It's not going to affect
the other nutrients. And then when we
look at the luteine and the zeazanthin
which is important for eye health, we
have twice as much in the pastured eggs.
So if you can afford it at all, then I
would strongly suggest that you get the
pastured. You either invest in health or
you pay for disease. Number five is bone
broth. And bone broth is very rich in
glycine, collagen, and proline. And
these are compounds that we boil out of
the bones so that your body can put them
back into bones. So it supports the
connective tissue which again is skins
and joints and tendons and cartilage and
so forth. And therefore to support our
joints and our gut lining and our skin,
bone broth is a great choice. And to
support the joints, we need to reduce
overall inflammation and then provide
the proper building materials to put the
joints back together and and repair them
properly. And this can help reduce
inflammation and reduce osteoarthritis,
which is part of an unhealthy aging
process that makes you stiff. And you
can also in in severe cases or as it
progresses, you can get the the swollen
joints on your hands as well. Not as
deformed as with the rheumatoid
arthritis, but still kind of thick and
clumsy and stiff joints. And the amino
acid glycine has also been shown to
improve sleep for some people. Food
number six is berries that are very rich
in two compounds called polyphenels and
anthocyanins.
And these compounds help reduce
oxidative stress and inflammation. And
in doing that, they help slow down brain
damage and cognitive decline. They help
improve signaling and memory formation
in aging adults. They reduce
specifically oxidation in the brain area
and damage in the brain. And they can
also help improve circulation, which is
super important as you age. But while
berries are sort of your safe sweet
treats, you still don't want to overdo
them and you do want to know a little
bit about which ones are safer in terms
of sugar. So, we're just going to talk
quickly about glycemic control.
And once you get over 50, what happens
is your metabolism slows down and your
insulin sensitivity goes down, meaning
your carbohydrate tolerance goes down.
So, you can't eat as much of them as you
did when you were 30, even if you
maintain or increase exercise. So you
want to shift yourself around to a low
carb and low glycemic diet. Now these go
hand inand for the most part but we do
want to understand a little bit about
glycemic index. So it's a measure of how
quickly you eat something and then it
becomes blood sugar. So if that happens
very fast it's a high glycemic index. If
it happens very slowly, it's a low
glycemic index. And pure glucose has the
reference number of 100. So,
traditionally, a low glycemic index is
between zero and 55 and a moderate is
between 56 and 69. And a high glycemic
index is 70 and above. But this scale
was created not for people over 50 who
are becoming insulin resistant and it's
also developed in a society where they
believe that carbohydrate and starch is
the foundation. They believe in the food
pyramid and they believe you should have
eight to 10 servings of grain and starch
every day. Now, all of that is not true
and this is why we have an epidemic of
obesity and diabetes all around the
world. So, I'm going to give you my
numbers. These are the official numbers.
I think especially as you age, your
green numbers, your low glycemic index
is 0 to 25. You have no business eating
anything that's as high as 55 or maybe
as an exception here and there.
Moderate is 25 to 40 and high is
anything above 40. And this is if again
you want to age gracefully. You want to
maintain your health and your brain
health and remain insulin sensitive. So
let's talk about some of the foods that
I'm recommending in this video. First of
all, meat, fish, and eggs have a
glycemic index of zero because they
basically
don't raise blood sugar. They can raise
it a little bit if you eat a lot of
them, if you overeat because the
protein, excess protein can be turned
into glucose. So, that zero isn't
strictly true, but just know that it's
very, very low. And next is non-starchy
vegetables. And even though the primary
constituent is carbohydrate, it's mostly
fiber and water. So the glycemic index
is also very very low between 10 and 20.
Now since seeds are also low, they're
between 10 and 35. And we'll look at
some examples there. And then berries
have quite the range anywhere from 25 to
50. And we'll look at some details.
Among the berries, the blackberries and
raspberries are the safest because
they're low carbs, but out of those
carbs, there's a lot of fiber that slows
everything way down. So, the glycemic
index is only 25. Next is raspberries,
which have a lot less fiber, but still
pretty much the same sugar. So, the
glycemic index jumps up to 40. They're
still pretty safe, but you don't want to
just go crazy on strawberries. Same
thing with blueberries. They have a
little more carbs and sugar, but not as
much fiber as the blackberries and
raspberries. So, the glycemic index
there is 50. So, these colors pretty
much indicate how you want to think
about them. Now, the red doesn't mean
you have to avoid blueberries entirely.
Unless you're a diabetic and you're
really trying to make a change, then you
would probably want to keep blueberries
out, but blackberries, raspberries are
going to be a whole lot safer and
strawberries are going to fall somewhere
in between there. Out of the nuts and
seeds, the safest are going to be chia
seeds at one because it's pretty much
only protein, fat, and fiber. So,
there's nothing there really to trigger
a glycemic response. and flax, hemp, and
pumpkin extremely low at 10. Also, we
have macadamia nuts, pecans, and almonds
among the nuts. Also at 10. And then at
15, we have walnuts, pistachio nuts, and
hazelnuts. And then at the bottom of the
list for seeds, we have sunflower seeds,
and sesame seeds at 35. So that's still
relatively low. It's not like you have
to avoid them, but also realize that
they're high in omega6 fatty acids. So,
they're not going to help you in terms
of that omega 6 omega-3 ratio. And even
though they're kind of low, just realize
that there are others that are much much
better. Let's talk about some of the
benefits of nuts and seeds. Among the
nuts, we have Brazil nuts, walnuts,
pecans, and macadamia.
And among the seeds, we have chia, flax,
and pumpkin seeds that are easy to buy,
easy to get. They're inexpensive and
they are some of the best in terms of
glycemic index, healthy fats, and
benefits. So one of the benefits and
this is of the Brazil nut especially
which we're going to give you a little
story on they have selenium which is
necessary for the production of
glutathione peroxidase and that's the
enzyme that helps the body make
glutathione and between the rest of them
they are high in fiber they're high in
protein and in healthy fats you can also
get a lot of minerals like magnesium
zinc calcium and iron from these nuts
and seeds. Also some vitamins B and E.
And you can also get some omega-3s in
the form of alpha lenolinic acid. And
this is going to be pretty much only in
the chia seeds and the flax seeds.
There's some in hemp seed as well, which
is not on list, but that's another good
one. And the ALA can be converted to the
necessary forms to the missing forms EPA
and DHA. But the conversion is so poor
that you don't want to count on ALA as a
source of EPA and DHA. However, the
omega-3s in nuts and seeds, they help
shift that omega-3 omega6 ratio because
if you eat enough of these, that's going
to help favor out that ratio. So, I want
to tell you some super important things
about Brazil nuts. And a very
interesting story because for years I
would muscle test patients in the clinic
and I would have them hold or taste
something and figure out through muscle
testing if their body liked it or if it
hurt them. And nothing showed up as much
as Brazil nuts. Pretty much I would say
more than 90% of people tested
sensitive. their body said that Brazil
nuts are not good for me. And I didn't
understand why back then, but I pretty
much told people to avoid Brazil nuts.
And then what I've learned since then is
that they are not just a rich source,
they are an extremely rich source of
selenium. Like ridiculously rich. They
contain about 45 times more selenium
than the next closest source which is
chia and sunflower seeds. But now get
this. Here are some numbers we really
need to understand. You don't have to
memorize them, but you need to
understand the magnitude of these. The
recommended daily allowance is only 55
micrograms. That's millionth of a gram.
A tiny tiny amount. However, there is a
toxicity level of 400 micrograms. So
only about seven times above the daily
allowance already makes you toxic. And
now get this, one nut is 90 to 180
micrograms. So you don't have to
memorize this. You just need to
understand the scope of it, the
magnitude. So, one nut can get you 160
to 320%
1 and a half to three times the
recommended daily allowance. So,
basically, three nuts would already put
you above the level of toxicity. And
this is why so many people came into the
clinic and they muscle tested as
sensitive to Brazil nuts because already
a handful is going to put you above the
level of toxicity. So the moral of the
story is that you need to understand
that there is a toxicity level and you
can safely have one to two per day or if
you don't have them every day maybe you
can have a handful but realize the
toxicity level and one to two is enough.
Food number eight is dark chocolate and
I can hear you right now. you're
secretly, silently cheering and saying,
"Yes, I knew it." And they're high in
flavonol and they help the endothelial
function and the release of nitric
oxide. And both of these are good things
for your vascular system. So endothelial
function means the properties of the
blood vessel how elastic it is how well
the muscles and the signaling works to
distend to dilate and contract the blood
vessel. So the elasticity of the blood
vessel so you can control blood pressure
and circulation better. And nitric oxide
is a substance your body releases that
causes vasoddilation that helps with
circulation. So both of these factors
can help improve the blood flow to the
brain and the extremities and that's a
very good thing especially to the brain
as you age to help maintain that brain
function. And you can thereby support
your cognitive function without the
burden of sugar if the chocolate's dark
enough. So let's talk about what that
means because we said as you age you
tolerate carbs less. So let's look at
the total carbs. Let's look at fiber.
Net carbs because total carbs is not
what is absorbed in your bloodstream.
The fiber is not digested and the fiber
slows down the uptake. So we subtract
the fiber from the total carbs to get
the net carbs. And then what we really
also want to know is how much added
sugar is there? because the added sugar
is 50% fructose which is going to work
toward creating a fatty liver. So let's
start with milk chocolate and that has a
total of 26 grams of total carbs only
one gram of fiber. Therefore, we
subtract the one from the 26. We get 25
grams of net carbs that can become blood
glucose. And out of that, 15 grams is
added sugar, which means fructose. So,
the difference here is going to be
mostly lactose because we add milk. And
then we have the first real dark
chocolate, which is 50% cocoa or
chocolate mass in that chocolate. So,
you can't really tell the difference in
appearance between 50 and 100 because
they all look very dark, but it has 18
grams of total carb, 3 g of fiber, 15
gram of net carbs, and 11 grams of added
sugar, which contributes that fructose.
But the difference here the between 15
and 11 is that there are some naturally
occurring carbohydrates in chocolate. So
they're not going to be as bad as the
added sugar and there's not a whole lot
of them and they're sort of slowly
absorbed. Then we get to 70% cocoa in
the chocolate. And now we're at 13 gram
of total carbs, four grams of fiber, 9
grams of net carbs, and 7 g of added
sugar. Now the way we're going to
understand these numbers between 50 and
70 and 85 and so forth that once it gets
dark and we don't have any milk added
then whatever isn't chocolate is
basically added sugar more or less. It
doesn't quite hold up but that's that's
the rough rule of thumb. So once we get
to 85, now it has 10 grams of total
carbs, five grams of fiber, five grams
of net carbs, and four grams of added
sugar. And if you notice the color
change here over on the added sugar, I
think that four grams in an ounce is
fairly safe. And what happens when we
get to the darker chocolates is that all
the fat is basically in the cocoa in the
chocolate mass in the cocoa butter. And
therefore, as the percentage goes up,
the fat percentage goes up and that also
helps slow down the absorption of the
sugar. Plus, they get very very filling
and satisfying. Whereas 1 oz of 85%
chocolate is quite satisfying, with milk
chocolate, it's very very addictive.
With 90% chocolate, we get eight total
carbs. We get six grams of fiber, 2 g of
net carbs, and 2 gram of added sugar.
Now, these numbers, if you're super
analytical, they don't make perfect
sense because the steps aren't exactly
smooth, but that's because of rounding
error. So, we're just trying to keep it
simple here. With a 100% chocolate, like
a baking chocolate or something, then
you get 7 g of total carbs. You get six
grams of fiber, one gram of net carbs,
and zero added sugar.
So
the 85 and above are the safe ones. A
lot of people are not going to enjoy the
100%. But the more you get away from
sugar in your foods, the better you're
going to like the higher percentages.
Food number nine is fermented
vegetables. And these are things like
kimchi and sauerkraut. Those are the
most common ones. But any vegetable that
you can ferment is going to produce very
much the same effect. So if you're
interested in doing that yourself, you
can look up recipes and ways to do it.
There are millions of them on Google.
And the reason you want these fermented
foods is that when you ferment them,
they grow bacteria. And these bacteria
are very friendly to your gut, to your
microbiome, and they help restore your
microbiome and your microbial diversity,
which is very important for health.
Because with aging, this microbial
diversity decreases dramatically
both with age and with antibiotic
exposure. And when our guts work better
now, we can notice an improved
digestion, improved immunity, and
improve nutrient absorption because what
the gut bacteria do is they basically
digest and repackage and prepackage a
lot of the nutrients for us. And your
gut is super important for the
production of neurotransmitters.
Most of the neurotransmitters are
actually produced there. And this is
especially when it comes to serotonin.
And a healthy gut also improves the
bioavailability, the absorption of
bioavailability of magnesium and zinc.
Food number 10 to eat as you age is
grass-fed liver. And if you can't stand
the taste of liver, then you can buy it
as a supplement as desiccated liver,
which just means dried liver. and they
either just press it into little
tablets. If that still has too much
liver flavor for you, then you can buy
it in a capsule so you don't taste it at
all. And the reason that we want to
consider liver as an important food is
that it's very rich in certain
nutrients, but also these nutrients are
highly bioavailable.
And this is iron, B12, folate, which is
vitamin B9, and also vitamin A. And we
want to understand that these are very
common deficiencies in the population,
but especially over age 50. And these
nutrients, they support methylation and
detox in the liver. They support also
the production of red blood cells. So we
can't have totally healthy and mature
red blood cells without enough of these
nutrients uh especially the B vitamins.
And the reason red blood cells are
important obviously is to distribute
oxygen throughout the body. And as we
age and our circulation might suffer
that becomes more important than ever.
And the nutrients that we talked about
in the liver also support your
mitochondria and your overall energy
production. So all the foods that we've
talked about, you want to think about
them not just as foods, but as powerful
resources that if you eat a wide variety
and you get good quality foods now, they
can address all the systems in your body
that tend to break down as you age and
you go to 50 years and beyond. And also
understand that it's worth learning to
cook. There are so many resources
online, so many recipes that you really
have no excuses. Just learn one new dish
per week. If you buy real quality and
you know how to cook it, then it's not
going to be boring food. On the
contrary, it's going to be the most
exciting, the tastiest, and the most
satisfying food that you've ever had. If
you enjoyed this video, you're going to
love that one. And if you truly want to
master health by understanding how the
body really works, make sure you
subscribe, hit that bell, and turn on
all the notifications so you never miss
a lifesaving video.